[Music]
[Applause]
what's the best job out there oklahoma
notre dame usc or lsu usc number one lsu
number two i'm sorry notre dame number
two then lsu number three hmm
would lsu grad marcus spears agree with
that
the span nfl analyst joining us on the
program good morning marcus best college
opening in the past week is where
louisiana state university but first of
all
dan patrick let me say this man i'm i'm
i'm almost i'm almost in kid
frame you're a legend to me brother so
thank you for having me man like i gotta
say that before we get into this
interview i'm geeked up i just uh text
my nfl live crew i was like i'm about to
go on that patrick show don't nobody
text me i'm not responding anything i'm
about to talk to the legend what's up my
brother oh and thank you for uh reaching
out or trying to reach out to uh say
congratulations for the hall of fame i
did get that message so thank you that
was very nice of you all right so
let now you got to remove yourself from
lsu
and you got to be an analyst here the
best college opening
is usc notre dame lsu or oklahoma
it's lsu dan and listen here's the
reason okay because i want to be on the
west coast in that beautiful sunshine
where you get daylight for a long period
of time you don't have to wake up super
early being a guy from the south and on
the east coast
but but here's the bottom line
three coaches have won national
championships at lsu
so we all know that it's doable that's
number one number two is you in the
center of where all of these five stars
all of these big time players come from
and in the state of louisiana which i
don't think gets enough credit for how
many really really good players come out
of that state as well and then two when
you think about brian kelly and you
think about his move but more
importantly you think about lsu and
where it is obviously people say well
nick saban is at alabama why would you
want to go coach there
two years ago in 2019 ed olgenron
fielded a good enough team to beat
alabama it's very few places that you
realistically believe
that you can do that and lsu is one of
those so that's why i feel like it's the
better job out of them and for a coach
to leave notre dame
and go to lsu should tell you what the
number one coaching job is in the
country well i also think that brian may
have thought let me be the all-time
leader in victories at notre dame
i'm i've done everything i could
possibly do and it's quite a resume
there and he turns 60
and i don't know if this is a midlife
crisis but he's probably had you gave
him an offer that he couldn't refuse and
probably said hey
i'm going to pull the rip cord and i'm
gone there and and i understand lincoln
riley as well going to usc with oklahoma
coming to the sec
i would want to be in a in a conference
where i thought i could stand alone and
oklahoma did that in the big 12 and i
think he's going to do that in the
pac-12
yeah lincoln lincoln made a phenomenal
choice and then too when you start
thinking about what he's been able to do
from an offensive standpoint i know it's
been said a lot the quarterback at
alabama is from california the
quarterback at ole miss is from
california so lincoln riley has enough
name cache he has two former heisman
trophy winners and two former number one
overall draft picks you don't think he
gonna sit in the quarterback house and
that's gonna be enticing to stay at home
in california and have the potential of
doing that at usc and then two that
program outside of pete carroll
is looking for in recent history
is looking for the next staple and i
believe lincoln thinks that he can make
that type of impact and potentially
become the guy that becomes synonymous
with usc football and so all of those
things are
are aligned for him not not to mention
look he was phenomenal at oklahoma but
bob stoops is going to be remembered at
oklahoma we know barry switzer is going
to be remembered as the guys at the
university of oklahoma lincoln raleigh
has a chance to go to usc and really
carve out a niche of being one of those
names like i said before dp that's
synonymous not only with the ability to
bring that program back to where they
once were with matt leinart and reggie
bush and all of those guys but also be
the young coach that can be there for a
long time and continue that cycle going
out there on the west coast i thought it
was a tremendous move for him i would
have loved to have let me say this i
would have loved to have lincoln riley
karelia lsu as a fan because of his
offensive prowess and that's something
that we saw with joe burrow that could
take hold in in at lsu but brian kelly
man it may not be sexy it may not make
you throw a parade but if you really
deep dive into the substance of it man
got a 75 winning percentage over his
coaching career that ain't nothing to
shake a stick at and he's going to be
afforded better players probably than
any ever anytime ever in his career to
recruit and have the chance to put out
there on the field yeah it's not a bad
consolation prize for lsu you played for
nick saban at lsu for four years yeah
did you have any idea at the time
that
coach would go down in history perhaps
as the greatest college football coach
of all time hell no dp i didn't know who
nick saban was i hadn't watched a
michigan state football game ever in my
life and uh it really came down to them
in miami and miami obviously was the
program my freshman year they won the
national championship that was with the
phenomenal team with ken dorsey and sean
taylor and john deville all of those
guys and i'm sitting there as a freshman
at lsu saying damn i could have been a
national champion my freshman year in
college but i i i just i i knew this
about nick saban through the recruiting
process and then through my first year
of playing because of my our first year
we had a really good my freshman year
had a really good season went and played
in the sugar bowl against illinois won i
think 10 or 11 games that year but you
could see that
let me say that you could believe that
what he was giving us what he was
teaching us how he was setting us up if
it didn't lead to winning if it didn't
lead to a national championship i
clearly couldn't figure out what the
hell you needed to do in order to win
one because the level of attention the
detail the coaching staff that he put
together and not to mention dp
jimbo fisher was on that staff will
muschamp was on that staff kirby smart
was on that staff derek dooley was on
that staff like so it was uh adam gates
was the was a was a um was a was a uh
what you call the the guys
a grand assistant a ga on that team so
it was at the time we had no idea that
these guys would turn out to be this way
but we knew we had good coaches we knew
that every game we played in we felt
prepared and had a chance to win and
eventually it culminated in winning the
national championship my junior year but
um i had we we we had no idea that nick
said we didn't know who nick saban was
but and this too for all of the
questions about will brad kelly fit in
dp you and i know it everybody listening
you win you fit in i don't give a damn
who you are or where you come from if
you win you fit into whatever culture
needs to be fitted into he's uh marcus
spears former nfl player espn analyst uh
you can see him monday through friday at
four eastern with nfl live with dan
olofsky ryan clark keyshawn uh mina
kimes and uh he's also on get up first
take weekdays on espn
um
i was watching last night with russell
wilson
you know a year ago they're 12 and four
marcus and we're letting russ cook
people are talking about mvp
now they're three and eight
how's this going to end
russ is out of there vp you can see it
i even said it
this morning man when i was going to get
up
is when you like the tone in that
press conference after the game
said a lot to me emotionally it looks
like rush is spent
it looks like pete carroll has spent and
listen it's been a great run but things
run their course you know i'm an lsu fan
when unless my when it was time for less
miles ago it was time it didn't mean
that he didn't have an amount of success
at lsu but it was time to go and that's
what it looks like to me it's almost
similar to what we see with the
pittsburgh steelers last year they
started running off wins early in the
season and you can start to see it tell
off and now we're coming back to the
conclusion that they held on to being
probably too long this team is not
really built to facilitate a veteran
quarterback going and having an
opportunity to win a super bowl so with
russ you look at seattle and yeah they
have something right make capitality
telelock is talented um the offensive
line has their issues which he addressed
defensively
brother they can't stop a damn nosebleed
defensively so
when you when you think about rush you
think about these quarterbacks that's
competing for championships aaron
rodgers is going to be right back in the
mix um tom obviously in tampa right back
in the mix
you look at these situations with these
veteran guys then they got to get around
teams that really has a great setup and
great coaching and offensive philosophy
and we've been throwing it out there and
the saints to me would be a good
location because of the synergy that i
believe he would have with sean payton
not to throw jameis to the wars he was
doing fine but russ is an absolute
upgrade but to me it just felt like a
like like finality after losing to the
washington football team and then from a
game breakdown standpoint dp how vanilla
and generic was that offensive plan
like that it was it you lined up dk
metcalf in the same spot you can't get
him targets we see the deep throws to
tyler lockett uh everybody gets excited
about that but in what world
does a russell wilson-led offense not
have
the ability to put up 24 points in a
game to be able to win the football game
but mark you can't convert third down
would you move on from pete carroll if
it meant you could keep russ in seattle
yes
if russ told me that
we needed i need to have a new infusion
of offensive philosophy and a different
way to approach it absolutely because
listen i love pete carroll pete carroll
one of my favorite coaches but what i
was saying earlier dp he's ran his
course in seattle man and and his
philosophy doesn't seem to be taking
hold there and we gotta let the legion
the boom go brother we gotta let it go
uh it's not there anymore this team
offensively is very generic they don't
have the same run game they had with
march tonight and the things i don't
think people realize how good the
seattle seahawks were
when they were winning super bowls and
we've gotten so accustomed to russ
making up for the things that they
lacked and still being able to play at a
very high level this team hasn't really
been
what you would consider even last year
you brought it up 12 and four but did we
really think they were a super bowl
contender i don't think at one point i
said the seattle seahawks saw a super
bowl contender it was all about letting
russ cook and how good he looked but
ultimately i think this thing has just
ran its course in his feet goals and
they get the right type of guy
potentially it could keep rust there but
rush his family life all of those things
i think are going to factor into him
maybe want to change locations
if i gave you a free shot
at keyshawn johnson
ryan clark or dan orlovsky
dan orlowski
and
i try to saw him in high fdp i got to be
honest with you and i love him because
he my brother but i would try to saw him
ahead because he has that little
stinking arrogance of a quarterback that
sometimes comes off that you just want
to like you just want to make them know
that you really aren't an athlete you
had a really good arm and you could
throw but you can't get a weight and i
would want to saw him in half i i
absolutely would and i love him i love
him like him have stayed at his home his
kids are my nephews and nieces but if i
had a shot on any of them it'll be dead
okay
yeah
i'm not
what if i threw greeny in there you want
to take a pop at my greenberg
yeah yeah i want to see how long he'd be
in the hospital
um hey it's great to catch up with you
we hope to have you back and thank you
again for all the kind words marcus my
man thank you man appreciate it it was
fun and have me back because if not i'm
gonna talk about your bad on something
that's okay okay that's okay
you won't be alone in doing that thank
you thank you marcus
that's uh marcus spears espn nfl analyst
and uh you can see him on nfl live
monday through friday at 4 eastern with
the host laura rutledge